à
84 ans yolande charti poursuit sa
carrière d'agent immobilière avant tout
pour demeurer active mais de plus en
plus pour des motifs financiers
une partie de ces économies a fondu elle
doit décaisser son épargne à perte on va
regarder ce qui hausse le marché s'est
de saveur parce que alors je sais que je
peux être obligé d'aller travailler
demain matin alors j'ai deux
qu'atteignant aux intérimaires dopés
ces immeubles à logements lagarde à flot
mais elle se demande si elle pourra
continuer de gâter ses petits enfants
comme elle le souhaite un choix morte ni
plus besoin
c'est lors que j'ai besoin de me faire
plaisir avec le haut puis de les voir le
jour les épargnants ont vu leurs
placements perdre de 10 à 20% de leur
valeur en moyenne depuis six mois c'est
beaucoup en la personne m soit 7
planificatrice financière voit de plus
en plus de gens reporter leurs projets
de retraite en attente d'une plus grande
stabilité financière faute de solution
miracle la patience est de mise suite à
une crise à une baisse et des allemands
ont fait pas de région change rien dans
le portefeuille parce que s'est
cristallisé la perte donc on attend que
ça revienne à 73 en lorraine mougeot
fait de la suppléance dans les écoles
dans son cas le travail est plutôt une
nécessité
votre perspective de retraite j'en ai
pas j'aimerais continuer à travailler
pour assurer ma survie autant le plus
longtemps possible
les embûches de la ville ont empêché
d'économiser pour ses vieux jours les
rentes du gouvernement seraient
insuffisantes pour payer son logement à
montréal nord là où il peut s'adonner à
son passe temps favori
l'observation des oiseaux dans le fin
fond je suis inquiet parce que je me dis
si m'arrive
un gros problème de santé et que je suis
dans l'impossibilité de travailler
ou est-ce que je vais aller et elle est
loin d'être seul dans cette situation
environ un canadien sur trois n'a pas de
fonds de retraite ce qui doit être
bonifié c'est la prestation de la
sécurité de vieillesse et le supplément
de revenu garanti
ottawa va effectivement bonifié de 10%
la sécurité de vieillesse dès juillet
mais seules les personnes de 75 ans et
plus ils seront admissibles comment se
fait-il qu'on métier toujours que ce
n'est pas ce n'est pas nécessaire qu'ils
n'ont pas ce besoin quand on sait
pertinemment bien que la précarité
financière elle est bien réelle chez ces
personnes là et que c'est difficile de
joindre les deux bouts à la fin du mois
faute de mieux lorraine voit son avenir
sur le marché du travail pour conserver
ses petits bonheurs violente aussi du
moins le temps que ces placements
reprennent du poil de la bête
ici jean philippe use radio canada
montréal